[Music]
welcome to Oxford Wendy duty local body
counselor hi I'm Hilary Musa the
librarian here at Oxford library we're
going to take you on a ticket or through
our new beautiful library that will be
open next week ok behind us we have a
nonfiction collection and a large print
as well as over here we've got a study
area and a space for activities so this
is our team collection through here and
the adult fiction we'll start over that
way and the books are all just being
loaded on as you can see this Phoenix I
love great excitement around it and even
this morning people arriving at the
library wanting to get in the door so
that's been kind of fun and this go all
going really really really well we've
got sylheti here you can hear we're
still doing it because the shelving guys
are still installing shelving is the
Mudassar moving the books and but what
we have here is a purpose-built facility
with a delightful new children's
that we just did
in the previous season and an enhanced
customer service centre and the beast
and the latest of me of library
technologies we're pretty delighted it's
really important to meet unit because of
the importance of part of a history of
our the soul building this is
interesting here Hilary we have got a
thin wall like you would have seen in
the kayak we library and in front of it
we've got the shelving we've got the
children's nonfiction and down the end
we also put in an interactive reading
nook so we've got plenty of seating
we've got the deep seat as well as the
school table in the larger table and
cushions for sitting on the ground
storytime and and of course you can
enjoy the beautiful view look at the
mountains over there with the snow on at
the moment quite excited about this but
once we've got a nice private room on
which we can sit on and do our JP
signing okay so over here we have the
council service centres this area so
it's a lot more spacious than what we've
previously had it is really exciting
everybody's very much looking forward to
coming into the building like to see it
grow it's been growing and getting very
excited about actually for the hive of
industry they're us and we are at the
moment
Monday will be over easy to go from
Wilkins and thoroughly enjoyed in your
environment
[Music]